welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Anders Wynne Roth forced family
professor of history at Yale University
professor Wynn Roth who was named a
MacArthur Fellow in 2003 specializes in
the history of medieval Europe
especially religious intellectual and
legal history as well as the Viking Age
today we'll talk with him about his new
book the conversion of Scandinavia
Vikings merchants and missionaries in
the remaking of Northern Europe which
recently won the macmillan centers
gustav Ranas International Book Prize
welcome professor Lynn Roth
thank you very much Meredith let's begin
with an overview of the book tell us
about it
well it's it's a book about conversion
about religious conversion Scandinavia
became Christian around the Year
thousand and what I'm trying to do in
the book is that I'm putting that into a
context looking at society at large what
else is happening at the same time and
in that way I'm trying to explain what
happened and why it happened okay
and what led you to write the book well
this is an issue that I have been
curious about for a very long time I
mean ever since I was a teenager I think
and I have always felt that it was hard
to come by an answer of why it happened
it was it was a fundamental and very
important shift in northern European
history
if one from paganism to Christian yes
and there were there were many other
shifts that went along with that this is
when the kingdoms may create in Sweden
Denmark Norway and so forth in
Scandinavia at the same time and I
always wondered why did it happen and if
one goes to the medieval sources there
are medieval where medieval historians
who wrote a thousand years ago about
about exactly this problem trying to
explain it but to them it wasn't really
much of a problem because they were all
devoted to
the energy so it was easy it happened
because God wanted it and it was God's
plan for Humanity if one goes of course
today historians generally do not accept
that as as an as an explanation right so
most historians use the stories that
that the writer medieval writers created
but they subtract the Christianity from
it and then you're sort of just left
with the skeleton and something that
doesn't really work and this is what I
felt needed - okay and what do you think
are some of the things that contributed
to the conversion well what I did was
that that conversion is something that
happens in society so I try to look at
society at large and try to understand
how Viking Age Scandinavian society
worked and again let's talk about the
time period what does it span well it's
the conversion itself is sort of the
decades around the the year thousand but
the book starts in the eighth century
and course goes into the 11th even the
12th century one has to take abroad be
sure it takes it it takes a while I
would imagine yeah yes exactly and that
many many parallel processes good so
what are some of the specific things you
think contributed to the conversion well
the the what as I said I looked at
society and what is what is exciting
about Northern European Viking Age
Society before there were kings there
were a lot of chieftains or petty kings
some of them thought they were kings and
called themselves kings and they were
they were competing with each other
about power about resources about about
money and the way they competed was to
try to to get as large armies as
possible okay and since they were not
kings is that when they were not rulers
of a state they could not just issue a
law and say you have to come to fight in
my army they had to persuade people to
come
and they did that by making people
friends by inviting them to great
parties in there in the Lord halls there
were many large halls each owned by by a
separate chieftain in Scandinavia at
this time and then they at the parties
they gave them you know feast they gave
them they gave them gifts what kind of
gifts what all kinds of things I mean
it's valuable things in particular they
gave them gold and silver gold and
silver rings to wear around their their
arms but also like swords with with the
gold on the handles and so forth this is
this is very well known that this was
happening I argue that that they also
used religion as one of these gifts they
could give them a sword and then the the
person who got the warrior got the sword
was very happy about it and most likely
to join the shift and when he went out
in war the next year he could also give
him religion he could give him
Christianity which was very prestigious
just like called why was it prestigious
though because the the great rulers of
Europe were Christian and people knew
that the great monasteries and churches
are you have been very very rich I mean
that's why the Vikings went out to take
those riches from from those churches so
they they associated Christianity with
power with wealth with all kinds of
things that are positive and thus it
goes got a positive loading itself right
okay now let's talk about how you did
your research and is it different
perhaps and what's unique about the way
you did your research I'll put it that
way well usually I work a lot with
actually medieval sources in in the
original in when I teach legal history
as I do this semester and do research in
it I actually have the students work in
the binary directly with the medieval
documents handwritten important and what
is the language though those were their
laughter
okay but for the conversion project that
there are very few written sources and
they have all been very well researched
and edited and I did not need to work
very much with original medieval
documents I looked at the modern
editions of it so what I did was that I
worked with with the texts that exist
and every few and are very very
difficult to interpret and but also with
reports of archaeological digs of which
there are very very many so I spent a
lot of time in the Yale library and in
libraries in Scandinavia Yale library is
really a wonderful place to do
humanistic research and we need to keep
it that way of course
okay what I'm curious about is during
you know those those years where the
conversion was taking place were their
churches building being built in in
those three countries well that ended up
being those three countries yes yes the
first churches we know were built we
know there was built a church into eight
30s in central Sweden that might be one
of the first Canadian churches but I bet
there was one in Denmark in the a
twenties but nobody says there's no
evidence for that and what about you
know there weren't you said there were
no real leaders that there were more
chieftains and tribes were they warring
constantly or was there peace did they
fight over their religious values for
instance you know they fought over a lot
of things but they did not always fight
I mean they were they they were
alliances they were constant network of
alliances that was constantly shifting
and in in inter punctuated all the time
by by open warfare instead but always
new alliances a very fluid situation
where everybody tried to get the upper
hand both by fighting but also by
persuading and by talking and by making
people your friend
it seems almost like it would be it's
exhausting to have to continue to give
people gifts in order for them to stay
on your side I mean is that the case
that it was like that yes yes and that's
that that explains the Viking raids
that's why the Scandinavians figured out
that that okay I need more capital to
use a modern term and I can get that if
I go to Europe and attack a monastery
okay so what do you conclude in your
book
well I my book is a synthesis so it's
trying to paint a broad picture in which
the conversion is fitted and so my
conclusion is is that you have this
society it is very fluid society
and you have these shifters that are
using they have a lot of tools in the
toolbox box for accomplishing the
political goals and what I'm arguing is
that that Christianity is one of the
tools just like pagan religion Muslim is
another of the tools many of them tried
to use pagan religion Christianity was a
better tool because of the prestige
associated with it thanks to the Emperor
and and the Kings so being in England
and so forth being Christian so they
were used as models yes okay well thank
you very much for being here with us
today and sharing some of your work book
is fascinating thank you very much how
many happy to be here okay for more
information about professor Wynn Roth
and his research please visit our
website at Yale edu / Macmillan report
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale